Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's a very
special Monday morning podcast that a,
we're actually recording on a
Friday and you'd probably be like,
why you're doing something so special
bill, because it's the holiday season.
You know,
I love you guys and a lot of you,
a real country to me on, on, uh,
didn't realize I was flying back from
my big whirlwind tour of shaking my ass
over there in Europe.
So on,
I mentioned in the podcast I was going
to have one of my best friends here.
Favorite people in the God damn business
has a huge comedy movie that actually
transcends the genre.
It's better than any Meryl
Streep drama from an Anchorman.
Two please welcome the one
and only Dave Kepner everyone
or a sounding boom bill burr.
What's going on man? Can kind,
yeah. Uh, how am I? I'm psyched. I
haven't seen them more. There you go.
That'll bounce around then your heads
for a second. Folks. You got it.
You got it out of the way.
I'm here with bill burr.
I cannot tell you how happy I
am. Folks. I know you envy me.
I envy me. No, they don't.
My podcast listeners, once
they heard me read out loud,
all the magic of anything
that I was doing went away.
What do you mean read out loud? When I do,
when I do the, uh, oh, the acidosis. Yeah.
When I'm ready to make funny you,
there's nothing.
I think they actually feel bad for me.
I'm, it's terrible. That's not true.
This is what happened. I sucked at
reading out loud and school and that.
So like now I'm reading out loud again
in the same thing happens where you're
just trying to get to the end of it.
So you start going faster and faster.
Like the amount of times that I
mispronounced my own name, your own name.
When I get to bill [inaudible] dot com.
What do you say? Like bill burr. Oh yeah,
it's embarrassing. I just start doing
it now. Like it's a golf thing. Okay.
And you know, I just realized how fucking
hot it's going to get in this goddamn.
So these were all things,
comedy podcast studios here for
the very first day interview.
And, uh, so we're, we're, we're working
out a lot of bugs. We've got, sorry,
we've got some echo.
I couldn't be happier.
Here's what we got and that
brought us some almonds. Yeah.
Because I'm going to enjoy an Alma. No,
they brought over a key here that ms,
she bought a beer. Okay. For
Bill and you also Brian Talents.
Let's make sure we get this out just
in case somebody lives under the rock.
Anchorman two,
the legend of Ron Burgundy.
It continues after fans for 10 years.
We're asking when is it continuing?
It's continuing right now when we,
it, it was supposed to open today,
but if they opened it Wednesday,
two days early. Oh okay. Yup.
That's why we scheduled this cause this
was going to be the exclusive opening
date podcast. Right. But only
with a great bill. Burb so they,
the paramount did the
switch. It's okay. Didn't,
they didn't clear it with Billy to dirt.
It's a dirty business,
dirty business fairly.
So they knew what was going to happen over
here and are unheated echoing studios.
They didn't want to be with you. So, um,
what I want to take your dose. So
I, last time I ran into you. Yeah,
I was over, over in Dublin and I
sent, I send you a picture, right,
for the listeners here. I'm, I'm in
Dublin sleepy, and I see a nice go by,
back us up a little bit, rot me all you
will back us up a little fucking cock.
So I'm thinking, you know, I get
a few tickets to the premiere.
It's in New York City, uh,
not in Los Angeles, which is
typical. And I'm thinking,
uh, bill was able to drop by the set
when he came through Atlanta when we were
shooting.
And uh,
you're so amazing and magnanimous and
everybody in the cast like outdoors.
We don't do this to that podcast.
Too Bad you're going to take it.
You're not going to give me shit.
I'm not going to be shot.
I'll fucking hype another
comedy. You'd do it. So anyway,
I still know what I thought.
I saw it coming out.
Bill has to be whatever the fuck it is.
Bill burr has to be here.
So I invited bill and
his wife and he goes, ah,
I have a show in Iceland that night,
which was last Sunday,
the 15th. So that's all I know was like,
Oh bill, it will be out of country.
Uh, I didn't, I'm not,
not unlike you guys.
I don't regularly check bills
blog. So I didn't know. Anyway,
I'm in London, so I put all my dates
on my blog write, I don't write,
I'm in London,
we're getting ready to do the premiere
and I get this text message from Bill
Blur. Yeah. Blow bar is I say [inaudible].
Yeah, it was coming from the uh,
the airport and I saw a bus go by and
it said at 10 we'll and all you guys on
the side of it and uh, it's,
you know, anchorman two,
the legend Romberg and continues.
So I took the picture and I
sent it to Dave going, hey man,
the hype in the cause they were
billboards where everywhere.
I was like the hype and the Shit out
of movie over here and the tablet like
Dublin, you're in Dublin?
Yeah, I'm in Dublin, Dublin.
That and I are London. I was in Dublin,
holy, shy, just fucking perfect.
And I, and I ended up doing,
and he goes, what? We got the,
we got to premiere tonight.
What time's your show? Em,
we can go out and drink a couple of
fucking Loggins put it. How crazy is that?
You can't make the premiere because
you're going somewhere else.
You're in Dublin the same night where
they're doing the premiere and you can't
do it because you're doing your
world tour of northern Europe,
but we'll call it all towards
sounds great. It's amazing.
I'll get to the rest of the world is so we
get was. So, uh, we do our little thing.
Dance Bill does his song and dance.
What the what theater, where were you?
I was at that,
the Vic Vicar Street theater
and I absolutely like so
much of my childhood now
make sense after that crowd?
I can't explain it man.
Just grown up outside of Boston.
And uh,
I think I told you those stories at night.
I mentioned them last Monday
on the podcasts. All kind
of, just to paraphrase him,
just not to bore the listeners, but like
I've been doing this bit about, you know,
hugging your children, saying, you
know, if your hug them too much,
they're pussies if you don't
do enough to become psycho.
So I always always weaving and go,
you know,
my mother didn't hug me that much when
I was a kid and no one has ever reacted
to that. And I'm like, literally like
15 20% of the Irish crowd just goes, aw,
breaking my balls. Like fuck you,
you need a hug you pussy now. It was,
but it was hilarious.
And then at the end I'm talking about how
I'm giving out a free DVD to everybody
who showed up to hopefully, you know, by
the carpet bomb my special over there.
Smart. Yeah. Yeah.
Well I guess I should've just put it on
Spotify according to this internet chick,
but a personal to have it.
Yeah. So as I'm telling them,
I'm giving you a free DVD that they're
listening and just some guy in the back
just goes out. Fuck off.
What hilarious. Wow.
Anything Nice. It was and
it was, it was no, but they,
they're doing it in a f yeah, breaking
your balls. And I told them, I said,
you guys have performed from a lot of
and miserable people be you guys are the
most miserable cons. And I didn't
even get to the end of the sentence.
They were already dying laughing.
Awesome. They were just like, uh,
I can't explain it man. Like I just felt
like these like I get it. I get like,
why I can't take a compliment.
Don't like fucking Nice Shit. If
somebody breaks my balls, I literally,
it will run through a wall for,
I'm like the second they look at you when
you think you lose your fucking shirt.
I'm immediately like, my heart fills
up like the fucking grand love.
But if you actually sit
there and pay you call,
you were trying to do at the beginning
of the podcast. No, I'll smash it.
Elastic chair over here. Like,
all right, that won't do,
I won't do that till you're a big
guy. When the guy from Missouri, yeah,
but bill burn, I got to
share a few pints, uh,
in some seller,
a bar of wherever we were staying in
Dublin with where the nice joints I guess
singing Christmas songs. Yeah. So
Your Cra and loud heal itself. Yeah.
Um, here's my favorite part of Dublin.
For me. We did this promotional thing,
maybe of the folks have seen any promo,
but we did all kinds of different ones.
And then this particular one,
there were some winners of some thing.
There were three groups of 20 and they
had gone on a pub crawl and at the end of
the pub crawl was a surprise. And it
was the four of us. It was, we'll Steve,
Paul and myself. No Way. When
this bar in Dublin called, uh,
I think it's to lease or Tony's Tunies,
it's one of the old bars. And uh,
so we're down there and we get a pint
of Guinness and we're like, ah, boy,
this is so needed right now.
This is perfect.
We just traveled from New York that
day. Ended up a bunch of press. Did the,
uh, we, no, this is before the premiere.
We're getting ready to go
to do a premiere and uh,
the owner of the place comes up to me
and he grabs me by the shoulders straight
on, right, right. Two on
either side. And he goes, uh,
you look like you enjoy a pint.
Tell me lad.
Oh yeah, Irish. I said, well actually,
yeah, my mom's side. He goes, I knew it.
And to me that's where the greatest things
that ever happened in my life because
he's like, you know, this is the best
pint of Guinness in all of Ireland. Right?
It's voted the best paint in
Dublin and knew what that means.
Was there a better pilot than Dublin? And
I was like, wow, I just went to heaven.
I know it's its way to these these people.
Then.
Then they'd bring them in in
groups of 20, we'd say, hi, hi. Hi.
They all had to gather round is take
one cup of white now they must freak the
fuck out there.
Let go.
They're all bombed now because they've
been on a pro pub crawl for you guys had
that wasn't so bad because the security
guys over there were amazing on the
international tour. They were like, okay,
here's what you're doing and take a
picture of boob. No more pictures. Boom.
You can't do selfies. You
can't do anything else. Get
out next group. But it was,
it was amazing.
So we did I think three pints
and a shot of a of Jamison.
This is making me wish I
was back there and yeah.
And then we went to the premiere and
this crowd was a mob in the greatest way.
It's the greatest energy I've ever felt.
And I asked will and those guys,
have you ever been through a gauntlet
like that? And they're like, no.
That was the most intense thing we've
ever been through. It was just love. Yeah.
They give it up over there. Yeah, I would.
You got to go to Scotland. Great. Yeah,
that whole area, man. Great. Great
Britain. Dare, dare, like, uh,
you know what's funny
as I've mentioned this,
like they're all going to get mad if I
actually say that people in London were
call half the people in England
are probably giving me shit,
but they're deaf and they're like the w
like each one of them has their own vibe,
the way they're coming at you.
And all of them kind of reminded me of
people that I like grew up with. Man.
Such a great, like if you're going
to Europe for the first time,
like that's such a great place to
start before you get oh yeah. You know,
cause Ireland, you know,
some people are like,
I don't want to not know the language
and shit. So that's a good way to,
to break yourself had before then you
start at zero and all these other great
places. Um, I was gonna ask
you, so like when, you know,
I've done like the standup tours and that
type of stuff and I'd done like radio
tours and shit. Like what is,
um, I mean, it sounds awesome.
You get to go to all these places, but I
know they like stick you in a room and,
and you just kind of go. First of all,
the hotels they put us in were amazing.
So and on this international thing, you
don't even touch her bag. All that stuff.
They pull the roll you up,
they put you each in an individual car,
which going back to what you know,
the way you feel is like, no, no,
we'll all write together. Yeah, you
don't need to put me in one like,
well there's a row row six cars with
one person in it. It's like, come on.
I'd rather write with my buddies. I
know. So the eagles, I heard the eagles.
So we do that.
They pick you up right outside the plane.
Like we don't even go to the
regular deportation thing
or not deportation, sorry,
immigration thing. They pick us up outside
the plane. They put us in these cars,
they take us a special little room.
They tenure retinas ideally right there.
They get your passports and you
wait in there. You have a ta.
If you want one or whatever,
then you're like on your way,
you don't even touch your bags,
you just go to the hotel. Oh fuck.
Did these movie stars Bitch about doing
these press junkets? Like that difficult.
That sounds fucking phenomenal.
Then they're too jaded and they,
they need to be brought down a peg and
they need to go out on tour and doing
standup at that little drink
isn't fizzy enough. Wow. That's,
I don't know how people get to that point.
I don't know how people get to the
point of bitching about convenience.
So that was amazing. We go through
all that stuff and then, you know,
then you go get a, have a pint,
a place like that. It was,
it was great, but it was like that
all over. It was, you know, uh, uh,
Australia we did and then we did a Dublin,
we did Sydney,
Dublin in London first class all the way
and yeah. So you had to sit in one room.
Oh wait, you went, you went to Sydney
first and then, then you came back to la,
back to la for Thanksgiving,
then New York.
I did Bristol did Sydney
Sydney's Greater Sydney is great.
You get a chance to look at
the beaches and stuff. I know.
Well I did climb some bridge. They have
your climb, which I didn't get to do that,
you know that is, yeah. Yeah,
but pretty amazing. So then,
but they take care of you all the
way. I mean, I feel so bad about it.
Like I need this suit
pressed is said okay.
If the pays for the suit because he's
been the suitcase and so want you far of a
deck, right. You've got to be
an asshole. Got It. You got it.
You got to add what is this into
your repertoire, right. So then, uh,
those first class all the way, it was
amazing. It's fucking awesome man.
But anyway, Billy couldn't come to the
premiere cause he's in Reykjavik, Iceland,
correct? That night. The
15th last Sunday. Yeah.
Crushing it and, or eating shit.
I'm not sure which way it went now.
I went good to the
understand you're back now.
Thank God they got bill burst humor. They
went great. I love that it's sold out.
I don't know, listeners sold out,
there was enough people that is,
that listened to, you don't know
half. Oh, I can't lie. I mean I think,
I think we did pretty good. I'm definitely
going, definitely going to go back. But,
uh, um, um,
I've been such a huge fan of
yours for as far as like the,
that full on cactus site and I did a
number of times and one of my favorite
characters is the,
as of Roy Roy,
you know what I love about it is it's
such a specific guy. Like we're not,
when I do like a gay guy, I do the
hackey one that offends them, you know,
like Jesus Christ. Guys,
can we all just be frowned,
which everybody has done.
Uh,
but on yours it's like the dude has like,
he has an eating addiction,
that one where he's, he's
cheesecake and one ever. Ah,
so Roy is at 350 pound gay man
who has a boyfriend's name is Roy.
He has two cats named Siegfried and Roy.
So it's really confusing and I'm
not sure which one's the most,
the biggest tomcat in the house.
It's my broil Dakar off. Okay guys.
He's passive aggressive. He's
aggressive, aggressive. He's made,
he's meaning please a suite because he's
hurt cause he wants to be loved and he
isn't in excel.
He lashes out.
He doesn't mean that it's such a fucking
like as opposed to my horse shit,
one dimensional things.
This is a fully fleshed out thing
like me and my wife needed neat.
We watched this and we'd
fucking laugh our asses off.
And then recently that terrains like that,
that crooked like bounty hunter one,
I actually came across that,
that I let creep along with like
the comb over. Oh Gerald. Yeah.
I'm not too familiar on him but that
was the another one completely. Uh,
he's a hillbilly cause he's,
he's a drifter,
a drifter and his best friends
or Hobos and I mean real hobos.
The guys that ride the trains has
named Gerald [inaudible]. Hey,
what's going on Bill Burr? It's
cold in here. What does that,
how do you, how do you cut it?
You come up with that shit.
That guy's kind of based on this.
This roofer drifter they came through in
my small town when I was 15 working at
my uncle's gas station,
beer joint restaurant.
And this is when you'd still pumped
gas and this guy was or make somebody a
steak. Yeah, I would. I swear to God.
Here's what a typical day was. In fact,
they're usually take someone's order.
You go back,
you get their soda or someone else has to
get their beer. You start their burger.
Ding, Ding. And remember the old
days when you'd go to a gas station,
ran over there,
there'd be an air hose that that red
that rang a bell inside the main summit.
Go pump gas. Dang. Dang. So Burger, you
don't flip it yet. You go out, pump gas,
get their money,
go give them their change.
And this is when gas was under a dollar.
This is 1977 under a dollar.
So go back end.
And then I dip my hands into the dish
soap that's in the sink. That's it.
There wasn't even a dishwasher dip 'em
in you rent some a little bit and then
turn that Burger,
throw some cheese on it and go
serve the God damn thing as it has.
His tank is filling up. Yeah. Dang. Dang.
He's inside his car with the windows
up smoking with the baby in the back.
He doesn't know. Yeah. That's actually
something, I bet if you brought that back,
do you think as far as
like a business model,
if you brought back an old school gas
station where it was service with service,
it's a full service thing and you
could actually get a burger. Um,
would people be willing to do
it? I know hipsters would. Yeah.
And they would pull up and act like
they didn't notice that this isn't what
every gas station is like. Right. But
like just for somebody, cause like for me,
like I was basically came of age in
the eighties but it was a kid in the
seventies so I,
I'm trying to think the lowest side.
I think I remember 89 cents a gallon.
Wow. Lotus. I remember something like, uh,
like the mid seventies or something, but,
uh, I, I've always wondered like if I,
that's, maybe that's just something
because I grew up back then. I'm like,
I would love if you could bring back the
shit that I remember that when you go
to New Jersey and you've got to wait for,
when you go to New Jersey,
you got to wait for somebody to pump.
Your gas is kind of a pain in the ass now.
Right now. I actually love
that. You do. I love it.
I love not getting out of the fucking
car and I'll pay the extra whatever a
gallon puts you,
let love it.
People and their eyes are bloodshot
because they're huffing fumes all day long
and you're like, Jesus, it's like
a peel. The toll booth workers.
I worry about them. Why aren't
you wearing a, an oxygen mask?
What was it like when you, you're a
Missouri Guy, right? Yeah. Growing up, um,
out there. What you athlete
football gloves. They'll look at me.
What we have bullying? Nothing.
No, no. I like six to 600 million,
but I grew up in Atlanta. You put
our bus driver and a full Nelson on.
You don't remember that. Well then tiptoe
while tipping over a fucking couch.
I know you're in rare form.
Well I had a few pints and I watched
Bill Bernie turned into the hulk.
Happy Pretty. She could put and
then Paul Rudd, but for the record,
for the record and drug me out of this.
Right.
And then rod put you in a full Nelson.
But by the way, if everybody listening,
it was all, it was all fucking around.
Yeah, it was fucking round. Yeah.
But then I apologize to bill via text
the next day and bill said that couch had
it in.
I was like,
cause I was shit phase two and
you kept tipping it over and pee.
We kept picking it up and every time I
look back you had tipped it over again.
What an idiot. No, you're
not. You're hilarious. You're
not tipping over furniture.
You're singing Christmas songs.
You're a a few self.
Oh Merry Little Christmas.
That's all we need to know.
We didn't know the end and have yourself
a merry little Christmas day that we
send it that we sent. What do we
say? I think we're saying gay. Okay.
We're acting like we couldn't remember it.
So we'd throw a different word and
every time I'm speaking to that,
did you see a,
well,
I shouldn't bring that up cause
everything's all controversial.
Or was it just said Duck Dynasty guy?
You know how long was it before anyway,
there's going to figure it those guys out.
You give that guy enough.
You know what? I don't understand.
I'm going to talk about some state,
so I don't want to run in the Bin,
but just the fact that they keep coming
after these guys who keep quoting that
book, why don't you go up to the book?
What's the book? The Bible. Oh boy.
You know why that pockets at too
deep. Yeah. So they go after Sunday.
Got just some guy shooting
pigeons on a boat. Yeah.
Well that shit was pumped
into his head when he,
before he grew his first whisker. Yeah.
You become like dementia. Every candidate.
Well has he made, is he recanted his
statement yet? Does he come out and said,
this is mia culpa and go on.
Sorry. It was my fault. Uh, uh,
he'll, he'll, he'll go
to some, there's just,
I don't think it helps homophobia
to make a guy loses his job.
And I think you have to come at somebody
in a more understanding way as opposed
to just like, uh, I don't know
how far you go on your podcast,
but I filmed him getting
a Bj from a super queen.
Okay. That's when he hit it.
He hit her with his beard.
So now he's trying to save face.
I don't know what's going on.
Why would I drag him into that? You're
here. Why not? I don't, I don't,
I shouldn't matter to me. I'm here to talk
to Bill Berg. What do I care about? Um,
but I don't care about that guy.
Whatever. Uh, you know what?
You learned your lesson. Hey, time to
evolve. I think that's the lesson here.
Like the Fox report is going to Santa
Claus is white. My thing. How can I say?
You know, there's Fox News shows said
Santa Claus is white. Isn't he fun?
The Netherlands what? And
Jesus is white too. Yeah.
Then he, he ever
happened? Yeah. I mean, I,
I honestly selling clothes at
react guy ever happened. Which one?
Santa Claus or Jesus. Oh,
Jesus. Santa Claus is real.
He's in your heart is in your
heart and your heart. Look,
I don't give a shit what color he is.
It comes down my chimney. He comes down,
he still does. Gives me a couple
of Cuban cigars, you know?
Is that what your thing is?
Cubans. Yeah. I Dunno. Listeners,
I allegedly might've brought some entity.
I enter the country in your luggage.
Are you uh, that's not a cigar smoker.
I can't do anymore. I used to
be carry a pitching. I, uh,
when I got to be about 45,
I'd always have a cigar at the end of
the night if I'm out with my buddies
drinking. And um, which was every
night. But, uh, when I was about 45,
uh, I had one deal, the nightmares, I
was like, oh yeah, they can get you.
If you get a strong one
and get half of that in.
I've done that and all send you start
puking like you play in a Frat can't do it
anymore. Yeah. Which is good. It's a
good thing. Not as a good time anymore.
I do it well. What I liked about
it was when you smoke a cigar,
this is feeling that of accomplishment
and whether you did anything or not.
So if you had a bad day, it's a
great choice. You know? I mean it's,
sure the health side effects is bad, but
it, it's, it's a wonderful thing to do.
You don't have to
inhaler, which, you know,
you just get mouth cancer and that lung
cancer I guess. Oh is that right? Yeah.
So what happens? You're not inhaling,
how do you get mouth cancer,
but just it's just, it's damaging
to the cells. I'm guessing.
I don't know what it is, but it has
less, probably less carcinogens than,
than cigarettes. Cause they fill all that
stuff with ammonia and everything else.
Well, can somebody figure out like how
many, you can have a month, cigarettes,
cigars, not die. Can
they hit you up on your,
on your website and let you know somebody,
there's a doctor out there that listens
to you, who will give you advice.
So any oncologists out there, I want to
give builders when you buy them overseas,
like they don't fuck around. I
go over here, it says, you know,
as surgeon general warning or did
they have, they go smoking causes, um,
mouth cancer and they show a picture
of a guys cancerous mouth time.
I was in,
uh,
recently I was in Toronto and I was buying
some cigars and I was at the airport
with a, I forget her, the one,
another comic I was looking
at, he was like, Jesus,
like the first time you saw, I'm kind of
immune to it because you've seen enough.
But I, at the first time I
saw it I was like, oh my God.
So I go through periods
where I've cigar smoking.
Obviously when I come back from overseas,
like I'm going to do some damage. Okay,
next. My you want as your wife feel
about it. Uh, she's cool as hell.
Dod Jordy, talk about your,
your marriage and, and, uh, uh,
what had happened and how it happened
because I don't know this now.
I didn't really, I didn't bring it up
because, so what's the best service? No,
I didn't do it. Yeah. Cause
I wanted to just, uh, people,
people know the name of my dog. They
know, you know, my girlfriend at the time,
they just knew a lot and I
was just kind of, it was a,
I just hit like they're not told
them that you're married now.
I mean when you go to my show is,
I mean, I say I am, but I have,
I guess I haven't said it
on the podcast yet. Okay.
I wanted to have something that was kind
of like, you didn't have a big ceremony.
No. Okay. Because I would have been hurt.
We buy and we went out to a duck pond
and we had a couple of homophobic guys in
boats.
Who Marius,
no big American flag headbands on.
Um, so anyway, if you had a reception,
what's the reception for your, for your
nuptials like a big party. A celebration.
Um,
just say no cause you invite me.
I think we had three. We had an engagement
party. I think we had an old farm.
Emmett, how are you doing dude? You're a
fucking movie star. You're flying around.
I didn't know you wanted to come to that.
Like I looked at it like I didn't know
you wanted to come to that or come on,
I'm in love of Bill Brown. She says,
here it is. I'm going to get shit.
You should get shit. Listen,
are you registered anywhere?
My registered anywhere you
register when you get married,
you were registered places for people
to buy you gifts with these questions.
Can you tell who handled everything?
Your wife? Yeah, I know I've done it.
Yeah, he went through it. It's good.
And as long as you give her a Christmas
card from us this year too. I've been,
I leave won't be good at one of the Bro.
I'm taking you off the list.
Just so you know. That's
all I'm saying. Well, this,
I think that's a little
challenge. Is it childish? Yeah.
You won't invite a guy to or something.
I felt like the staging point.
You met him,
you had this chip on your shoulder.
So why don't we not agree now
the way Aaron everything out.
Why don't you just get it off your
goddamn chest. The bag of almonds
and
smells.
Very nice. Um, sports affiliation.
Sports are big on this podcast.
They're gonna wanna know Kenzie g,
some commie Pinko kindly you watch city
chiefs tends to say cheese right here.
I think they're gonna make the super bowl.
How do you think he coached?
Looks in the new red versus read.
Doesn't look good. I me come on,
but don't matter. I think he's lost a few
weight. A few pounds. I think it's good.
I think he, I knew he could hide when he's
in Philly with that forest green. Yeah,
we can't hide. You can't, you
know, reading is not slumming.
All I know is the dude is winning.
He brought in 24 new coaches.
He's changed the organization.
They weren't,
they won two games last year and now
they've completely turned around. What?
We weren't nine. Oh, okay. Uh, were
the winning is captain, are you buying?
Are you selling? Oh, nice. That's
good. This, this comedian, uh,
for shall we were talking about that
stupid segment that they have on one of
those sports channels. He buy it,
he'll sell it. Kansas city chiefs,
the chiefs in the playoffs.
You sitting there with the plastic helmet,
two mugs of beer. You've already
beaten half of your children, right?
You're ready for game time.
W what do you think if you get home field?
Well,
who is stopping the chiefs?
Denver's done it twice so they can't
answer the third time. They can't yet.
And one of the only say on ESPN,
I'll tell you right now,
and it's really difficult to be a t three
types of one year. Not going to happen.
I like it. But who are we going to
wind up with patriots to the Paychex.
I want it done in the playoffs.
Tom Brady.
Tom Brady's haven't one of his best years
and people are sitting to going has he
fallen off? It's just like
everybody's been injured. I,
one of our best guys went to prison
and we didn't get anything for him.
When you got goes the president,
you don't, yeah, you don't
get draft picks. Okay.
And then,
and then our best guy at every level on
defense is as either been out or is out
for the season.
Our Best Linebacker,
I best down Lineman to week two of our
best down lineman and keep to leave like
the, our, our, our guy,
you just ignore him on that side
of the field when he's playing.
He said he just had a hip injury. Um,
it's been really a difficult year.
And then somehow if we
didn't lose last week,
we were actually in the driver's seat.
They have home field throughout the
playoffs. I mean him and bell check.
It's insane what they've
been doing this yet. But um,
you can, you can fool people.
And the regular season, I'm
not going to name names,
I'm not going to be a dick,
but there's a lot of people that
are absolute monsters, um, in,
in the regular season. And you get
to the playoffs, it's a different,
it's a different, everybody has a good
defense. Everybody has a good offense.
You might get away with it for a week,
but once you get into that second week
and forget about the third week, so,
you know, we've, you know, we beat some
teams that aren't the greatest teams,
padding our victories.
But I know when we go to the playoffs,
like I don't see us like
beaten the ravens. I mean,
I know Ray Lewis and those guys aren't
there anymore, but I just, they, oh,
they weren't with on there on the
foot. They want on their, on their, uh,
the kicker last week. Who did, uh,
the ravens. I did they, I mean, I've,
I've laughed. I missed the last
two weeks of a football. Oh,
you've been traveling around the
world. Wow. Remember that folks?
Bill's been around the world. He's
better than you. No, I haven't.
I've just been better than you.
Hi, I'm Bill Berg. As what?
One thing you should know,
I'm better than you feel better than you
podcasts like that. No, I'm actually,
what I've been telling them last week
before you paint me with your broad brush
over there is that she
read, she's brush. I, yeah.
I say how bad I did in high school.
How much I fucked up in my life.
That if I can get to this,
you can do it too. There you
go. You're right. Yeah. Huh?
Have you, the fans heard your coaching
bit? Do you still do that one?
Which one is that? The,
uh, coaching you're talking
about? The Rutgers coach. Oh,
you know, that was a topical one, so
I had to kind of sound good. Yeah.
You know, a couple times I'm being on
stage and I'll remember, I'd be like,
that was really fun. So
good. So good. And you know,
do you don't do Schwartzenegger? No, I
put that out on the last special. Well,
I've had this run, you know, that thing.
I did a little bit of the
bit on on Conan and uh,
I ripped some of it that I
hadn't done. Um, which was the,
the disgrace channel and all that.
That was just something I
literally thought of that
night on the show and I was
like, ah, that would have had a lot
of legs. But once I do it on TV,
it's like I can't do it.
But the bit that I've been doing
it just interchanges with names.
At first it was Paula Dean and
then it became Riley Cooper.
You did the panel when that night
too and then it was somebody else.
And then yeah,
when I go on Conan and I always have some
sort of topical kind of thing that I,
I tried to do,
um,
I'm working my way up to have the
courage to tell a story on those things.
Cause um, you know, like I'm
not you, I'm just, yeah, I'm,
I'm getting my feet wet
as far as doing panel,
you guys are all experienced to him. I've
only done them a few times. So when you,
when you do a bit on national television,
you never do it in your act anymore.
That's it. No. Wow. Wow. Hmm. I
shouldn't say that. Like if I,
if I do a, like if I did stand up on where
it's, uh, you know, give us five minutes.
Okay.
And I do like a minute and a half
condensed version of an eight minute idea,
then yeah, I'll do it again.
Um, or if I touch on it,
if I'm doing panel and for, but I
don't go out on panel, like going,
I'm going to do bits.
Right.
It's more like I'm going to be having
a conversation and it's sort of a free
association. Right. And then
it's like, if it comes up great,
it goes well how about, how about the, uh,
hardworking mom's bit that you did on
Letterman? Did that go on? Especially,
I know, but like the Steve
Jobs thing, that was so good.
The Steve Jobs thing that
he did on native, too many
stores. We, yeah, that isn't,
but what I liked about
that was they, they, um,
they kept the whole piece of it. So
what I like about that is, you know,
I'm an old school music guy,
B sides and stuff.
That's a cool thing where it's
just like, oh, you can't get that.
You have to go on Youtube, got to go
find it and you got to go find it.
And if people just start finding out
my comedy, they see a special goal,
I want to see more of this guy. Like if
they'd just keep seeing different things.
What's gotten you the most attention
on Youtube? Philadelphia? Uh,
Phil was probably,
it was probably the first thing I
know I want to try to tell people.
Sherry's berries from a few weeks
ago was another one that got along.
When I tell people what they should
check out, bill burr on, on Youtube,
what should I say?
I say watch the thing in Philadelphia,
that's not his thing.
He doesn't take on the audience,
but it is so fucking beautiful that that
will give you the full essence of what
you have done as such.
Now.
You know how it got out of that and all
honesty was just knowing sports and,
and I lucked out where it was,
is this,
all those teams are there.
So I was just outside of Philly.
And you had teams from DC and
the Redskins hate the eagles.
You had people from Jersey and
the Redwings hate the flyers here.
People from New York and the Rangers.
But the next part, the plugin giants.
Was it 15 minutes? How much? How much
time did you have? It was 12 minutes.
12 how much longer? I'm during the fall.
12 yeah, I don't care. That was the best.
Well gale force winds of
ignorance blowing in your face.
Don't know how much more time. All
right, here we go. Look at you.
You're fat. Fuck. I hope you
have a fucking heart attack. Oh,
I don't know if I would
say it was of ignorance.
I would say it was more of a mirror that
the reason why I do well in front of
those drunk moron crowds is because
that's basically what I am, what I am.
That's who I hung around with.
Like,
and I don't mean like more and like
seriously as I should have done,
but you know those guys,
when you go to a sporting event,
being protective of your audience,
don't just the guys who are,
who are in your section and that Dick
Day are drunk and that kind of scaring
people,
but they're making this section laugh.
Those were the guys kind of
guys that I hung out with.
Those are the guys when I went
to sporting events, I like them.
So throughout the years,
like it just becomes a part of you and
then you do your act and then you attract
that. So when, when they're yelling at
me, I mean it just feels like, you know,
the Boston Garden when they would old
days when they would call offsides is some
bullshit penalty against the Bruins
and all of a sudden you feel like carry
Frazier when you're down there. But
it's a familiar, more of a uh, uh,
a familiar sound. What do you have
club owners like you cause your,
your crowd drinks. Absolutely.
Mine does too. They go, oh,
you bring a drinking crowd. No
one. They love it. They like that.
And then you know what's
good too on the late show,
if you really want to hook
up, uh, the correct one to
kiss ass to the comedy club,
you tell the club owner and he said,
all right, if I go a little bit longer,
just put last call. And they love
it. They'll push it a little bit,
a little bit more. Yeah. You
get them that extra round.
He gets one extra round going
all the way around the room. Do,
do 15 minutes to do an hour
when you want it to show. Uh,
well at this fits theater is different
than a club and the club, do you have, uh,
if I, if I have an, uh, well I only got
one guy in front of me and theaters.
If I've got two guys in front of me,
I'll do like an hour.
If I only have one guy in front, me, I
do like an hour and 15. If I have to,
if I only have one show, I'll go
longer than that. So this, um,
this hour that I've,
I've written, you know,
I kind of was working on
a couple of standup skills
that I figured out how to do
them and then it wouldn't need to figured
out how to do something new. Yeah.
What Jack Lemmon, dude, come on man. You
got to keep getting better. I like it.
I liked that one. I liked I was Chang
what Jack Lemmon is my guy, Jack Lemmon,
19 boy he did,
he did the apartment and he,
I think he was nominated for an Oscar.
Okay.
And that was like in the early sixties
and in 19 early nineties when he did Glen
Gary,
Glen Ross,
Jack Lemmon in the early nineties blew
away Jack Lemmon and the in the early
sixties.
And there was that thing where despite
the fact that he was where he was at,
he kept going in and like I think what,
what uh,
you got to watch out if you create
for a living is when you do fill,
you finally fill up a place
and to get like, okay,
can this license not even, or you just
go, okay, this is my bag of tricks.
This is what they want me to do.
I don't want to divert from this
because I might lose this. And uh,
then then your creative life becomes
like that movie groundhog day.
So there was a couple of things
I've been working on and what,
what they did was they ended
up making three minute fits,
five minute pits in six minutes.
It's nine minutes and I'm not gonna
I'll say off the air what it is cause I
don't,
I don't want pull,
you just said you just figured
out some new standup thing.
Would you say some skills you said?
Yeah.
You just figured out new standup skills.
And when you mean is like you've been
able to extend bits or what do you mean
skills? I'll tell, I'll tell you. Well
it's like, I'll compare it to athletics.
Okay. Okay. Let's just say
you know your, your, uh,
you can't go to your left.
Oh.
So in one summer you just work on going
to your left and then everybody in the
leagues like, Hey man, he can't go to his
left. So they're working on your right.
You go to your left, you start scoring
more points and it's like, fuck,
he's doing this. And the
next year, what do you do?
You start clamping down on defense and
you just keep working, working, working,
working at that little subtle things.
And,
and then hopefully if people are
watching your specials close enough,
they're seeing the improvement.
And I've had people come up to
me a few times and said, man,
I've noticed some this special,
you went from this to this
and from this to this one.
Like my last special was
a transitional one. Um,
there was things that I was trying to
do in that one that I felt like I almost
landed but didn't quite land and now
and then those spy continued working on
those skills. This is one after
Fillmore? Yeah. This is the, um,
the fuck was that one called was my
last one called you people all the same
people. Okay. Um, so that
one was a transitional one.
All right. Like, um, why do
I do this too? To let it go?
Was me learning how to do that and then
I felt like I got it. I'll let it go.
And then this one, the last one. So I'm
hoping not to put pressure on myself. Um,
um, you know, but this is the,
this is, this is like, um,
what keeps me going and I'll write
it in an hour. It becomes like this,
not like this dreaded thing. Like, Oh
fuck, how do I come up with another hour?
You get excited. You're like,
I'm going to go left. Yeah. I'm,
I'm going to work on this
thing that I suck at.
So you feel like when you're going down
they, even though your strips traveling,
I just had to say it.
I can't imagine what you think you suck
at and no one else would think that.
It's because I've learned over the years
how to be struggling and make it look
like I'm not, I'm not even
bullshitting too. Like there's,
there's, yeah, there's, there's
all these fucking tricks,
which I would tell the fans, but
it would ruin them watching. Sure.
Like I'm not going to say what I'm
working on. Oh, I don't want to them.
Because then they stop listening and
laughing. They start watching like, oh,
that's the thing he's working on. Is
he sweating? Does he look comfortable?
So you know off air, I
can do it. I know, I know.
I can't figure you out anyway.
To me it's all a dream,
so I'm just like watching this thing. I
don't know how, how you put it together.
Then when you write, you write every
day. No you don't. I don't. Right.
Do you try and write all Tony v a
long time ago, a comic out of Boston.
I did this movie,
the heat with him,
he was in not the Brotherhood on
showtime for some fucking reason.
They left me hanging after the second
season. It's still kills me. Um,
you should definitely watch it, but
it's such a buzz kill to get to the end.
Like they set this whole is based on
the bolt yours. Yeah, White Whitey.
And that was his other brother's
name there, uh, Billy Ball jar.
And it was literally the biggest
gangster in the biggest like politician.
And when you're like yt bolt,
you're literally won the lottery.
He won the fucking lottery. And, and
uh, I don't know. The depart is based,
but basically it was,
guys are still so powerful that I
heard that when they did this, uh,
they made this movie, they switched
from Boston, this series. I'm sorry.
They moved it down to providence.
So it was based on that relationship.
We had one guy was,
one brother was a politician and the
other brother was a gangster and I
absolutely fucking love the show. Anyways,
Tony Memory was in that show. Yes.
And Tony Vee was in it. And, um,
like Tony Tony was the first guy,
first comedian Tony view was
the first comedian that I met,
also another cigar smoker. Um,
so I love running into him.
He was the first comedian that I met that
did not write down any material really.
And it blew my mind. And I
was just like, and I was like,
so how do you, how do you write?
And he goes, well, I go up on stage,
I just start talking about it.
And I just asked him like two or three
questions that he asked. I asked a bunch,
but two or three there, I
remembered the other one was, well,
what do you do when you forget a joke?
What about this great bit? Your hand,
you and you just forget to
do it? And he goes, well,
that just means it's
time to stop doing it.
And through listening to guys like him
and then starting off with a guy like
Patrice O'Neil, rest his soul,
who's the best comic ever saw. Um,
and he,
he,
he naturally knew that from day one,
like Patrice,
you still like he used to write in the
shower and he used to joke him and Dan
Cook. Dean was another one.
Dan was another guy. He said I,
I would think of shit in the shower.
And they were joking one
night to each other saying,
because when you're in the shower,
the water going over your head.
Sounds like an applause break. Oh,
that's so everything. It's all ego.
So everything, no, they were joking,
but say it just sounded like, you know,
like you are killing on stage.
So I I, that's interesting.
I will tell you the best bit I've ever
written was in the shower. Are you joking?
He's not joking at all. Yeah,
I'm not joking at all. It
came to me, the shower. Yeah.
I used to think as shit when I was in
New York, I used to, when I used to walk,
I used to walk around the city talking
to myself at night after I did shows and
that's when I came up with stuff. And
I used to be that guy. You need to,
I need to write.
And I would sit down with my notebook
is before fucking laptops and shit.
I'd sit down with the thing right.
Or at least when laptops,
we had like 40 pounds and then I would,
um,
and I just, one day it just dawned on me
like I think a shit when I walk around.
So I would just start going for walks,
uh,
in New York and go walk around
New York at night. I mean,
it's obviously a dangerous thing, but
it's also a great thing. Um, you just,
you just see the city in a different
way and uh, you just start, it just,
you start connecting stuff and then
there becomes this thing where you can't
write it down cause you're there and then,
you know,
cause you're not right cause
you're walking around. Um, and so,
and then when you get down to the comedy
club, if you can't fucking remember it,
that it was worth you, you gotta let
go of it. You have to, you have to,
you've got to just think back when you
were in high school and you will making
kids laugh.
He didn't have a fucking routine.
You came to school every
day and you improv.
And if something funny happened
to you, oh, on the weekend,
you didn't rehearse it,
you didn't do,
you didn't go to a buck 20 other fucking
high school cafeterias and try it out
and then go out there. Hey guys, I love
that I a wacky weekend. She just did it.
You did it and you acted it
out and you imitated people.
Maybe you stood up and you just did all
this shit because you are comfortable.
Yeah. So it's, it's really,
it gets you to that level of
comfortableness that you had with,
with your friends. Yeah. So that's what,
what you try to work towards where you're
as comfortable offstage as you are on
stage. And then you don't
have to necessarily, like,
I'm not gonna lie to you, man,
if I come up with, write a line or I'll
write a word, I usually do a word right.
Like, like for this,
this thing tonight, like,
I'm gonna go fuck around with
this thing tonight. I don't,
I kind of know what I'm going to say.
Um, where are you going up tonight?
I'm going to go up,
down to the comedy store.
You go up how many times a week
and when you're on tour? Yeah.
Well, because it's like going
to the gym if you don't,
I don't want people coming out on tour
to see me and see like three shows where
I'm at. Can, he's shaking the rest
of them. That's not fair to them.
And that's also a major, uh, uh,
fuck over of yourself
because they're not gonna,
they're not gonna come see
you again and they shouldn't.
We went on a double date one night
with bill and his now wife and uh,
so we go out to dinner and didn't have
plans for later and were like, oh,
we're just going to go see a movie.
Couple of this. It's a Saturday night.
And Bill's like, Nah, I'm going to go do
a set. And I was blown away. I was like,
what?
You don't have any really?
That was amazing to me. Yeah. I
just meant to me, it's like, wow,
you're never going to get there kicking
her whatnot. Well you also have you,
you got like how many kids?
You have like 19 five kids,
but we were just going out I guess.
I see. Yeah. I need to go out.
Well why we think the,
although the amount of material that's
at home but people don't want to hear
about your kids. Yeah,
they do. Yeah, they do.
Guys come up to me go eh,
too much kid stuff and I respect that
because Ah, some drunk in Atlanta.
Oh there you go.
You know,
I got to tell you where I've gotten in
my business in this show, businesses, I,
I've, I've based it all on some drunk
guy in Atlanta. Oh. Like, like his,
because I think that too is like,
I wouldn't want to just sit around and
just hear about your kids all night.
When I used to watch Carson Cosby
himself, fine. Is it, I have that.
It's like a fucking hour and a half
special. I put that right up there with,
with Richard Pryor, the one he did out
on long beach and with the red shirt I,
those are the two best specials I,
I've seen as far as like, you know,
just totally freeform
saying, you know, using all,
we'll call the language and
then work in clay. That's,
that's to me that is the whole comedy
rainbow as far as working totally clean.
A little bill says, Bill Cosby
says a asshole one time. Big Deal.
But like that is basically
him talking about his family.
And I saw that when I was like,
I think 14,
13 when it first came out and I loved
it. I watched it a zillion times. Okay.
And uh, I'd say is a great, is
a great standup thing to do.
I did it accidentally on an airplane.
Somebody next to me was watching bill
Cosby himself and I couldn't hear the
audio, watch it with the sound
down. He's fucking unbelievable.
Like you think he's just sitting there
killing you don't realize all the shit
he's doing because when he's taught,
when you hear that voice and
that thing that what he does,
I mean that guy is and,
and, and this is like the,
and this was him like like 30 years
ago. Right. But he's got just a little,
he had a whole attitude and just
one eyebrow raise. Yeah, no.
Did you ever see that? The
Seinfeld documentary? Yeah.
This is really getting comedy nerd
here, but I thought, but people like,
did you ever see the Seinfeld
documentary comedian, comedian?
Just so you know, Bill was hold a
clutching, uh, the micro Mike Sand.
He was likely to remember the name of it.
He was holding the microphone stand.
He was holding the cover of the DVD
was, I am known for night. Okay.
Remember what did I say earlier
when I was trying to say,
I know what you did last summer.
I said, no, he did last Sunday.
I'm the worst with those.
Terrible.
So my favorite part in that movie is
when Seinfeld goes to meet bill Cosby and
you see this guy, you see Seinfeld, first
of all, he turns into like a little kid,
you know,
like you just see him hanging on his
every word and caused me does this quick
little thing where he talks about,
I forget what it's something about
like drying the crowd in are gone.
It just makes us,
he makes this little movement with his
face and either he the lean forward or
came back and I was in the movie theater
in my seat and I leaned forward to the
scroll. I was just like,
this guy is a Ninja.
Like he's unbelievable. So getting back
to what you said when you're going, like,
you know, you're still working on stuff.
I mean, I am like that guy, you know,
I just got off the ground.
Like that guy is in like,
he's like fucking out there with
those, uh, those cell phones,
satellite fucking things going
around the handles. Like so, um,
and I think that there's so many
unbelievably talented
people out there and, uh,
that you get sucked into doing other
things like writing scripts and that type
of stuff, which I'm not saying
it's a bad thing, right?
But there's just something about
standup comedy that I like.
That's where all my goals
like. So, uh, yeah. So I,
I keep working on that and then any acting
work I get, I just considered it as a,
as a bonus. It should be in fan fence for
years. You've promised me yes, that's,
you are going to hook me up in all
your movies. I was putting your hours,
the guy and he said, listen, I'm doing
this little stock car movie called uh,
Talladega Nights. We didn't
know each other. How do you,
how do you look in a virus? Know
each other then? And I, and I,
I cried when that movie came out
and you didn't put me in it. Okay.
Well I taught year old virgin, by the
way, when we did pay in that barrel,
are well aware of you and they love
you. Didn't put me in. Just so you know.
And you take it, you fucking
take this case said, yeah,
Bill Burr might be the best out
there right now. So take it. Oh,
he says he's too busy editing
movies. Nope. He gets it.
He knows a feral knows. They
know. All right. Listen,
this is about you, my friend.
Let's stop with this. What I want to
talk about is you. So there you go.
That's of me. Well, have you seen,
have you heard about Sherry's berries?
I'll give them a shoutout.
She did.
They're chocolate covered strawberries.
I do it. Yeah, for Christmas. Yeah.
Kind of lost my shit when I was, I was
trying to read because there's copy was,
I couldn't figure out if it
was homoerotic or homophobic.
It just kept going. One, you know, you
should see the size of our berries.
So that was like homoerotic and then
you get to their phone number and it was
like call eight, six, six fruit. What?
Fruit? It's like a homophobic, damn.
It was just, it was fucking, he reminded
me of that sketch. Remember that?
That Alec Baldwin, that's Schwetz what
it all still, it was literally like,
I thought it was a joke. So, and plus I
was, I was jet lagged or whatever. So, uh,
I think I, I'm going to see what that,
when that one comes in, I'll see how many,
I think I sold a lot. Yeah. Just by
acting like Sherry, Sherry's berries.
So I gave him, I gave him a free
plug back. That's good. So, uh, yeah,
what King Bucket,
I'm going to go into press junket here.
What can people look forward to seeing
here with the new anchorman or not?
I don't want to get away in India. Okay.
And here's the deal. You've seen it yet?
No, because I'm trying,
I'm trying to, we can all,
I'm trying to coordinate with like
five people where we are the biggest
anchorman nerds. That's awesome. And
it's like I want to go with all of them.
I want to go during the
day so there's not a,
I want to be able to hear
every joke and I personally,
I want to see it a good three times
before I buy it on laserdisc DVD.
And all that. Dude, when we
were doing that, when you saw
us in Atlanta, we had, we,
we wants to watch the movie like five
fucking times. It's like our, uh,
what's that? Mr. Smith goes to Washington.
That's like our movie was me. Uh,
Jason La had the duty hugged and Paul
Versey, my buddy, uh, from New York,
you got to meet him at great guy and a,
um, a hilarious guy and we would just,
we would just pop that thing in.
Um, and it's just a good joke.
Oh, that's not the second
they get, you know,
made Frank Sinatra look like a
Hobo Nike. And we ended up in, in,
in our pajamas watching him. So I'm
so fucking excited to see this movie.
I'm so happy for you guys that,
that they able,
I remember asking for years on my planet
the fuck are they doing another one?
You were like, I'm going to be
going, like, this script is written,
the script is written and
what, what, what is it?
Because everybody download stuff now. Like
why, why did it take so long? Oh No. Uh,
for a couple of reasons.
First of all,
cause Adam and we'll weren't
keen on doing sequels. Okay,
I hear stand that and then
the movie wasn't a hit.
It only made 85 million domestically is
a modest hit so that there was no demand
from the studio.
Like let's get more money.
Well it made 85 box office,
which is not huge.
You know, it hits $100 million.
Then you're like, okay,
let's make another hundred million
dollars cost to make that one costs 24
million. And then you, they figure
they've spent uh, 20 million of market.
So that's 46 million. All
right, let's, let's, let's,
let's bring it to regular people.
Regular people numbers.
If somebody put 240 bucks yeah,
down at the track and then they left
with 850 bucks, they'd be pretty psyched.
Right? They'd be buying drugs for
people. But I would definitely say, hey,
let's do this again. I liked the problem
is they put down how much? 240 bucks,
put it at 240 bucks.
Then you made 241 that was more like
it because what you only get half the
revenue from the, from the
uh, uh, you also spent,
you put $48 down or have sold $44.
That's $24 million to make
the movie. Then grosses. Yes.
Then $20 million to, to
advertise the movie, not,
it's $46 million you spent on this movie.
Now the movie makes $85
million at box office.
The student gets half of that. Okay,
so there's still in the, in the red,
he still walked with 200
bucks, right? 200 bucks. Well,
200 and your world is 20 million.
No, no, no that, none of that.
They get half of the 85. So
they only made 40, 42 43.
So they're actually is only making 43
million backers. Then you broke even.
That's all they did all with you
have Italia. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You spent $20 million in
advertising prints and advertising.
So the real cost of the movie was $46
million or $44 million. So that wasn't,
they didn't get a huge profit.
So do you really just have to be a
crook to somehow get over the bar?
We'll know what happens. Is that making
you money? If you, if you make a,
if they make $100 million now
they've made $25 million and a happy,
so they are just looking to make their 25
million. Yeah, it's all a business. Okay.
Nobody cares about if it's good or not.
Did I make money and I blame them?
They're in a business.
So I've always said that.
What happened later then was
DVD sales and cable reruns.
It became a hugely popular movie
and after about six years ago,
it became this thing like wow,
something's going on with this.
When you saw the tee shirts and the
quoting everywhere in pop culture,
it went away. Now who got the
money on that? Oh, paramount.
So their property also, they
made all the weight. So the guys,
the guys that you're talking
about didn't make any money.
You're saying that's paramount. Didn't
initially as part. Okay. Okay. All right.
So then it was clearly there's
something here. Then people were like,
anytime I'd go on a press
junket or Steve or will or Paul,
they don't know how you're moving.
What about anchorman two?
It became this cult phenomenon,
which can became a pop culture phenomenon.
I was like, you couldn't ignore,
there's a big thirst for this picture.
And then the studio picked up on it
and then whatever it was two years ago,
they weren't planning on doing it,
but then they had something
fall out of their schedule.
And so Adam and we'll approach them
again. They said, yeah, let's do it.
Then there was a little haggling over
the budget and then, uh, because they,
so did you get to the fore?
You ever get on the phone if there's
as possible for way phone call?
Was there any like, no, there
was no hesitation. Kitty,
can you fucking believe we're doing this?
That only happened when we
all met together in Atlanta
when we were shooting the
first,
uh,
last week of February one start to
interview or this is what I should got to
what? So what, what was that
stuff? We'll have to wait.
They've got to fucking enjoyed
bill burr. What, what, what is,
so what was that like when you guys,
you got the band back together? No,
before that we got together to shoot
that little teaser, a commercial, uh,
after we'll had announced it on
cone on county again with the flute.
That was awesome. That was awesome. We
met and did that teaser trailer, right.
You know, coming in a year
and a half your too. But that,
that was so early. It was, but we did
that so that they couldn't pull the plug.
There's like,
there's no way they can go back and we're
going to announce that he announced it
there. Now we're going to do
this teaser. So here we go.
So that was an offensive move. That
wasn't like the studio going, hey,
go put on your costume. He was like, no,
we've got to make sure that they're
going to do, let's put one out. Let's,
let's keep goosing this thing. And uh,
but I'm sure pair my paid for that.
So they were new, but we'll make the
announcement so there's no going back.
So the first day you were in Atlanta and
you're shooting and the first day you
go down, it's in a scene involves
shooting off for you and your on.
The first day that we got together was
a day where we recorded some stuff in a
um,
looking at a picture here somewhere,
recorded some stuff with the studio
cause there's a song in the movie,
there's a song we recorded for the
movie that didn't make the movie,
which is going to be out on DVD later.
I'm such a big fan of actually
downloaded the music already. No,
I downloaded like what was that song
off the first one? Uh, afternoon.
Oh yeah, yeah. Brandy.
No. From San Francisco.
What does nameless,
I'll roll enough.
The ships and here's what they had to say.
Ride cab.
I kept my head upon your mystery ship.
We playing that on the bus man.
After we finish clinic a Gig,
the next morning we wake up,
we start cranking that.
I don't know why I took six
years off this, this phone.
I had a picture of us the first day
we got together. Recorded. It was,
it was nine years later. It was
amazing. I'm sorry I can't find it,
but you know Adam and,
and Judd and a will, Paul,
Steve and Christina and myself. And that
was, that was like, wow, here it is again.
That's nice. Finally, when it
was getting at the first time,
you guys were actually,
we were dressed up in character and you
at the cowboy the day that we shot that
little teaser of does that thing where
he doesn't move his arms straight down.
Right. That blew me away when I, when,
when you let me come down that day, uh,
just let people know I was
doing a Gig in Atlanta. Right.
And somehow you knew I was there and
you say, hey, you want to come down to,
I knew you were coming to
Atlanta to do, do a show. Right.
And you have to be in town that night
too. That was unreal. We went down there,
the set visit. So we go
to, I'll tell it starts.
So we go down to a t to the
anchorman set and, and we're,
we're sitting at already
smiling going like,
what the fuck is this going to
be like? We don't, you know,
we were ready to be like
quiet like church mouse.
It's like we'd go down there like,
just don't get in the way.
You don't piss anybody off. Don't step on
any cable. And we go down there and uh,
and the first one we go to meet,
we go up to your trailer and they knock
on the door and you knew it was us in,
in and Dave,
you know,
you fucking Barstow open the door and
you start going like he's gesturing
towards me the whole time. It's me and
Jason Santana. He just goes, the man,
the myth, the shouting across
the parking lot, the legend.
You'd had all these things and you start
walking towards me like you're going to
give me this big bear hug. And at the
last second as I reached out to hug you,
you make it,
you,
you've cut a hard right and just give
a big bear hug to my buddy. Jason,
you left me hugging air.
I had fell for like one of the oldest
comedy tricks in the book. Yeah.
And then you give Jason this big bear hug,
like he went to war bearings your face
and his neck and he's laughing his ass
off.
And then that was it.
And then we started walking down to the
set and then Paul Rudd comes out of the
trailer,
pulls a big fan of yours,
totally dressed as Brian Fantana
the whole fucking get up.
But he's talking like him. He's
like, oh hey man, what's going on?
And I'm fucking saying hi.
Like I was trying not to be that.
And we went down to the set and that's
what killed me when I went down there was
the scene involved. All you guys, and
I got to see you guys talking before.
And then the second day
you guys are getting ready.
All of your body language changed.
And you became those guys. You know,
like when I say Steve Kerr, I
was like, you know, talking.
And then all of a sudden his
arms just go straight down.
And we were sitting there like, he's
fucking brick, right? He's being pro now,
you know, and, and, uh,
we'll was signing off doing
something and he did some little,
like that little pound on the desk,
like he had done a good job, you know,
like little that just the way I just,
which was unlike any of the
other characters that he's done.
So just as a comedian, just
watching that, that skill level,
uh, uh, as, as an actor was just, it was,
it was fun. And I gotta tell you when we,
when we left, um, oh, and well was great.
He's totally stayed in character
and trashed. Jason. Um,
I forget what he said.
He just said, Oh yes,
I've heard wonderful things about your
talking to me and you're getting just
points at Jason, but you just a litany of
horrible, just one of those whole thing.
And so we ended up, I'm
smiling now. We got an,
we got into the cab and went back and we
shot there just like ear to ear fucking
grins. The whole I'm telling you to
do. That was one of the coolest, uh,
coolest fucking thing that's
ever happened. So I, I'm
so beyond sight that this,
this thing's coming out. So, uh, how, how
many days did it take you to shoot it?
I think there were 55 days on
this one and there were 45 class.
And that is that relatively
quick for something like
that? A quick normal, normal.
There's normal, uh, it's, you know,
relative to budget you want 60 or
something like that I think is 55. Um,
the first one was 45 days, which was
a long one for that kind of budget.
It was all here in town. Um, so yeah.
Oh you shot that first one here?
Well yeah.
Is here and there like one or two
days in San Pedro and then uh,
or Piedro depending where you're from.
And then I think they just did some
exteriors in San Diego cause all the San
Diego thinks it was shot
there. Right, right, right.
But it wasn't exactly exterior's
only was the Jack Black scene,
but it pumps the dial. Nope.
When was that? That he was
here somewhere. Some bridge,
some bridge in La.
All right,
well what else do you well,
how long have you been doing here?
I've got to make sure I don't want to
keep them too long. 60 minutes. All right,
look at me. Feel in an
hour. Perfect. We can,
I know what I'm going to
do the standup tour in, in,
in January, February, March. Uh,
go to David kenner.com and
you can check all the dates.
I think it starts in Boston. E.
C. H. N. E. R. N. E. R. Yeah. Uh,
or follow me on Twitter at David Kempner.
Uh, then there'll be some, you know,
follow the links and all that stuff,
but I think I started in Boston and you
get the ones hunters going out to the
Wiltern. I can't remember where it,
okay, cool. So smaller theaters.
I call my boss and fans out there. Come
on man. You got to curse those things.
I'll, I'll hit you up. Definitely.
There you go. I'll hit you up.
And that full on Keckler thing. Is that
a, uh, is that your own Youtube Channel?
My Youtube Channel, but I just
signed a deal to do a thing with NBC.
So I'm gonna do a variety show.
So those characters,
those are those characters will
make their way onto that stage.
I do those characters on stage to uh,
and Bill Burr, we were talking earlier,
has some stuff perculating
some deals someone should make.
I don't know this about you.
It's about, you know, care.
I want to talk a little Burr,
so I've got a TV show sound that's coming
out that's definitely different than
fucking guys movie. Cheap thrills.
She throws up. Yeah, it's a,
it's a sinister of thriller with dark
comedic undertones. I didn't think it was,
I didn't know. It's funny, we shot
that in 12 days in Los Angeles.
I think I made like $25 a day to shoot
this thing turned into a masterpiece.
It's wonderful little film.
It's dark.
And I watched it twice with
festival audiences and I
couldn't believe their last,
I had no idea there were last
in this movie. And I thought,
now how do you describe this thing? I
thought it was, is this thriller? Right?
But now it's got, it's one of the darkest
comedies you'll ever see. Awesome.
So where can people see? Well,
it's going to be out in March. Uh,
and it was called cheap thrills. Cheap
thrills. Yeah. So I'm excited about that.
And your back catalog,
what she have favorite movie thing that
you did that I did that you did that
didn't get the attention you felt it
did just to steer some people suddenly
extract. I got to play this character
and extract, which is a Mike Judge Film.
This, this nebbish neighbor
that just tortures, uh,
Jason, um, pavement Bateman.
Thank you. I kept thinking,
right man, Jason Bateman and
it was so much fun. I could
do that for 10 years. Oh,
cool. Yeah. Just a neighbor, this neighbor
that and nudge and you're like, oh God.
And it is that,
is that up on Netflix or anything?
I'm sure it will all be up there.
And there's a thing that happens to
him badly in the end of the audience
applauds. Oh, the guy,
he's so annoying now that's gotta make
you feel like you did your job when you
go to the female. And they told me that.
Yep. Absolutely hated him. All right,
well listen man, this is
the first interview here at
the brand new wall. Things,
comedy a studios. We forgot to talk about
Jay Moore. Oh yeah, you mentioned. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm a huge fan of his, we both love
Jay Moore. He's not been on Ipod podcast.
He has not now have you.
And he's complaining and he's
complained about it on Twitter.
So as you can see up on the board,
right.
I Have Jay more big boards somewhere
on the bottom around like 72nd.
I did 75. Oh, you'd like, we're
going to, we're going to get that.
There's a line that says guys who
probably won't get to. Yeah. Jay Moore.
I'm just spraying, I'm breaking
chase fucking balls. I love Jane.
I got to get him on this podcast,
but I've been on tour.
He was breaking my balls on Twitter, so
I'm just fucking with them. All right,
well I'm gonna break his balls
tonight. Uh, so who does,
who does better impressions than Jay
Moore? Um, well, I've never, he's,
here's the thing about Jay Moore.
He broke the impression for Christopher
Walken low. Let everybody else do it,
dude. He does. That's amazing. He does
Colin Quinn. I'd vide lovers. Quinn.
I could lead to a does Harvey
Keitel he's amazing. I would,
I love sitting there and do a Collin
Quinn with him cause it's so good.
A Cielo Collin, right? Yeah. I Love
Colin Quinn. Fuck yeah. Uh, but,
uh, more almond joys. Alright,
well [inaudible] Chaim or sports?
Uh,
you're not going to be on this podcast
ever, Huh? I Bet I got to get them on.
Nope, I got it. Gallery guests
we had on, that's the cupping.
I think the last gasp. Dot. Some
but not JV. Dom. I rare I had on,
I looked down but not Jay Moore. Not
Jay. I have not had him on. Hey Jay,
can we sing him a little
Christmas before we go? Yes. And
Chris's Summers,
uh,
show I be on this podcast. He will
be. He will. I'm sorry chairman.
I've been on the, I'm on the fucking
road. You can't, um, that's it.
That's the podcast. I don't even need
to see ghosts. Go see anchorman two.
I know you're going to see it.
You got that one coming out.
She throws cheap thrills, trust.
Look for his new show. Meantime,
go to [inaudible] dot com at day Teknor
and checkout full on character on
youtube. That's all I can do to whore
you out, sir. I love, I love you too.
All right, brother. Thank
you. All right, and.